[Aplausos]
[Música]
una pregunta conocéis
probablemente si fue uno de los
fundadores de paypal el primer inversor
en facebook y es uno de los gurús de
tecnología y capital riesgo más
importantes del mundo por supuesto es
multimillonario y sobre todo un tipo un
tanto curioso entre sus hazañas está
financiar por ejemplo proyectos para
construir ciudades en alta mar o
investigaciones para luchar contra la
muerte pero peter thiel también es
conocido por ser el mayor apoyo de
donald trump en sillicon valley
es verdad pero en conversaciones con
periodistas ya ha demostrado dudas
además qué diantres todo el mundo
nosotros los primeros tenemos derecho a
equivocarnos no os parece el caso es que
en 2011 peter times consiguió la
nacionalidad neozelandesa se convirtió
en todo un kiwi y dijo esto estoy feliz
de poder decir que no he encontrado otro
país que coincida más con mi forma de
ver el futuro que nueva zelanda la
verdad lo sabéis en visual político esto
es algo que no nos sorprende ya os hemos
contado en dos vídeos anteriores que
nueva zelanda es un país que nos encanta
no solo porque es uno de los países más
bonitos del mundo también porque es todo
un ejemplo a seguir
fijaos en estas declaraciones en bromas
del primer ministro bill english sobre
el anterior primer ministro
en ocasiones yonki se quejaba de que era
el único líder que no tenía un avión del
gobierno y de como sus colegas estaban
horrorizados al enterarse de que tenía
que viajar en aviones comerciales pero
yo le aseguraba que eso reforzaba su
carácter y le mantenía en contacto con
la gente normal si nueva zelanda no
tiene avión oficial a cambio es el país
del mundo donde más fácil resulta hacer
negocios es como ya vimos el país más
próspero uno de los menos corruptos y
uno de los más seguros de todo el
planeta
[Música]
y ojo porque los servicios públicos son
de bandera como ejemplo os voy a contar
una experiencia personal veis esta
tarjeta pues es mi tarjeta del servicio
de bibliotecas de oakland en este país
amigos las bibliotecas son algo
impresionante cómodas con wifi de alta
velocidad gratis con bancos de música y
un montón de servicios de verdad os doy
mi palabra' están muy muy bien montadas
es algo que merece conocer porque
sorprende y tan solo en oakland
hay 55 bibliotecas públicas pero no sólo
eso como sabéis es uno de los países con
más nivel de vida y más empleo fijaos
por ejemplo en este gráfico
[Música]
vamos que el país merece la pena ahora
bien no penséis que siempre fue así
[Música]
no siempre salió el sol
nueva zelanda es un país top pero amigos
las cosas a los kiwis no les fueron
siempre también para nada lo que vamos a
ver a continuación es una historia real
la historia de un país que tuvo la
determinación de aprender de sus errores
de transformar todo aquello que no
funcionaba y convertirse así en todo un
modelo y ojo porque no hablamos de algo
que sea precisamente ni fácil ni
habitual poner a las personas por
delante de ideologías y de intereses
electorales no es nada común al menos en
los países de habla hispana no es cierto
salvo alguna cosa pero seguro que te
estás preguntando pero qué es lo que
pasó pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
hay que decir que nueva zelanda siempre
fue un país relativamente rico de hecho
a finales de la década de los 50 este
país tenía el tercer ingreso per cápita
más alto de todo el mundo nuestra mal
verdad sin embargo esperado un momento
porque a partir de ese instante las
cosas empezaron a torcerse hasta el
punto que en 1984 atentos el ingreso per
cápita de nueva zelanda estaba a la
altura del de portugal o turquía tal
cual como lo escucháis y claro puede que
ahora te estés preguntando qué diantres
hicieron en este país para que esto
pasara pues podemos decir que al
gobierno se le fue un poquito la mano
por aquella época el gobierno de nueva
zelanda tenía intervenida la economía
hasta un extremo que hoy cuesta
imaginarse
[Música]
había muchísimos impuestos eran
complejos y muy altos para que os hagáis
una idea el tipo más alto del impuesto
de la renta llegaba casi al 70% y por
abajo casi al 40 que se dice pronto y
desde luego las empresas no salían mejor
paradas el impuesto sobre beneficios era
del 48% el doble de lo que hoy es
habitual en el mundo además había
montones y montones de regulaciones pero
es que montones controles de precio para
casi todos los productos controles de
divisa por ejemplo cualquier importación
requería la aprobación expresa de la
administración y los neozelandeses
tenían muy pero que muy complicado
invertir su dinero fuera del país
teníamos controles de divisas que por
ejemplo significaban que no podía
comprar una suscripción a the economist
sin el permiso del ministerio de
hacienda fijaos hasta donde llegaban los
controles y las regulaciones que no sólo
estaban fijados los salarios mínimos
también los máximos
tal cual como lo escucháis por ejemplo
si un empresario en un momento dado le
quería pagar un bonus a sus trabajadores
bueno digamos que era una tarea cómo
decirlo complicada si de locos
[Música]
y por supuesto como ya os podéis
imaginar el estado era dueño y señor de
prácticamente todas las grandes empresas
nacionales telecomunicaciones aerolíneas
compañías de seguros bancos hoteles qué
diantres hacía el gobierno gestionando
hoteles vamos en otras palabras la nueva
zelanda de principios de los años 80 era
todo un ejemplo de estatismo llevado
casi al extremo de una forma u otra
prácticamente todo era controlado por
los políticos y los burócratas las
consecuencias pues no precisamente muy
positivas
tras 23 años de déficit en las cuentas
del gobierno la deuda pública se había
disparado el desempleo superaba los dos
dígitos la inversión privada huía
despavorida del país y los jóvenes kiwis
que es como se llama a la gente de este
país se marchaban en masa claro por
aquel entonces hacer negocios en nueva
zelanda era algo complicado algo sólo
para valientes y claro así pues no se
puede ahora bien en 1984 hubo elecciones
y todo empezó a cambiar
[Música]
un plan para salir adelante
en 1984 bajo un contexto de crisis muy
dura se celebraron elecciones y las ganó
el partido laborista de david long y el
partido de centroizquierda
risk
de ese país adquirir el nuevo gobierno
llegó con una misión superar la crisis y
cambiar el modelo de país sustituir todo
lo que no funcionaba y asegurarse eso sí
de que nadie se quedase atrás pero al
mismo tiempo que a nadie se le impidiera
avanzar pues bien aunque david long fue
el primer ministro el líder de todo este
proceso fue el ministro de finanzas de
roger daghlas con lo que se vino a
conocer el roger no mix y window live
com 20 max wright
huevo todo listo y con a break y baile
aquí en visual político ya mencionamos
este plan en un pasado vídeo cuando
hablamos las reformas agrícolas que
tanto éxito han tenido en este país
roger daghlas impulsó un ambicioso
paquete de reformas conocido como roger
no mix que liberalizaba muchos ámbitos
de la economía y que en el sector
primario pasada por eliminar los
controles de precios y suprimir la
mayoría de los subsidios ayudas públicas
al campo pero el roger no mix amigos no
se quedó solo en la agricultura para
nada
afectó a prácticamente todos los
resquicios del estado y puso en pie una
nueva cultura política de hecho cuando
unos años más tarde en 1990 el partido
nacional el partido de centroderecha
neozelandés ganó las elecciones y volvió
al poder ya todo había cambiado y el
nuevo gobierno continuó la estela del
plan laborista una filosofía política
que entre 1984 y principios del siglo 21
cambió radicalmente el país todo esto
que vamos a ver amigos no es visual
político es la historia
[Música]
dicho esto lo primero que hizo el nuevo
gobierno fue declarar la guerra a la
burocracia y lo hicieron de tres formas
primero hicieron un examen minucioso a
cada departamento del gobierno si lo que
hacían no era imprescindible o lo hacía
mejor el mercado pues punto y final bajo
esta misma filosofía por ejemplo se puso
en marcha un ambicioso plan de
privatizaciones pero de las de verdad no
de las de regalar empresas públicas a
los amiguetes del poder
pensarlo un momento y asia le estaba
perdiendo el tiempo gestionando hoteles
aerolíneas o telecomunicaciones gracias
a la competencia el mercado lo puede
hacer mucho mejor con menos costes y más
innovación para el camarón forman en
google adwords curso de cultivo a la
prueba de arranque a fandom elegido para
el primer papel y constitución de
culpable textil salón 6 de consumo agudo
text para let's uy no hay campo segundo
muy interesante en 35 agencias públicas
que continuaron siendo públicas como
poder
el sistema de control del tráfico aéreo
se profesionalizó la gestión y se les
exigió que funcionasen con criterios de
mercado
el resultado fue espectacular no sólo
mejoró el servicio sino que estas 35
agencias públicas pasaron de costarle
mil millones de dólares neocelandeses al
gobierno a generar entre beneficios e
impuestos más de mil millones dinero que
podría destinarse a educación sanidad o
cultura
pero ahí no acabó todo en absoluto como
las regulaciones y las leyes eran muy
numerosas y muy complicadas el gobierno
puso a las mejores mentes del país a
trabajar con una misión simplificarlo
todo y eliminar todo aquello que
realmente no aportación a da el
resultado de todo este cambio cuando
comenzamos este proceso el departamento
de transporte tenía 5 mil 600 empleados
cuando terminamos tenía 53 cuando
empezamos con el servicio forestal este
tenía 17 mil empleados cuando terminamos
17 ojo el desempleo
se redujo hay una historia muy cómo
decirlo descriptiva lo que pasó con los
ciervos sí con los ciervos no me
equivocado fijaos cuando los británicos
llegaron a nueva zelanda en el país no
había grandes animales así que algunas
familias de dinero llevaron ciervos para
poder cazar y que creéis que es lo que
pasó pues que estos ciervos se escaparon
y se convirtieron en una plaga que
causaba un daño ecológico muy importante
durante 120 años el estado había gastado
muchísimo dinero en tratar de combatir
esta plaga para preservar el ecosistema
local
[Música]
pues bien un buen día con tanta reforma
surgió una nueva idea porque no dejar
que los campesinos pudieran cazar y
criar los ciervos pues dicho y hecho
no sólo terminaron con la plaga hoy
nueva zelanda es el mayor proveedor
mundial de carne de venado tiene sentido
verdad también es muy interesante lo que
pasó con los impuestos que se
simplificaron y se redujeron
para sorpresa de algunos la recaudación
subió un 20%
[Música]
[Aplausos]
los subsidios por su parte se cortaron
no sólo en la agricultura también en la
industria pero ojo no os penséis que las
reformas fueron sólo económicas para
nada éstas afectaron también a los
servicios públicos mirad lo que pasó por
ejemplo con la educación durante años el
presupuesto no había parado de crecer
pero los resultados eran peores acaso es
que los estudiantes kiwis se habían
vuelto torpes no nada de eso cuando el
gobierno investigó las causas se dio
cuenta de que una parte muy importante
del gasto en educación iba a parar no a
la enseñanza sino a cosas
administrativas agencias de la
evaluación de la calidad agencias de
calificación agencias de expedientes
etcétera etcétera y que creéis que hizo
el gobierno si se lo cargó todo y le dio
el control de los colegios a un consejo
de dirección elegido por los propios
padres
[Música]
no sólo eso también permitió que fueran
los propios padres quienes se escogieran
libremente el colegio ojo público o
privado el gobierno pagaba y ya os
adelanto que los resultados educativos
mejoraron mucho pues bien así con todo
[Música]
ojo insisto tener una cosa muy clara
nueva zelanda no es el salvaje oeste
para nada nueva zelanda es hoy un país
muy próspero con un nivel de vida muy
alto y unos servicios públicos educación
sanidad cultura etcétera que están entre
los mejores del mundo así que me
pregunto qué mejor ejemplo para
latinoamérica o para países europeos
como españa italia grecia o portugal las
cosas se pueden hacer mejor pero claro
hay que atreverse a dejar a un lado las
pasiones y los españoles muy españoles y
muchos españoles y ver qué cosas
funcionan y cuáles no en fin si algo
está claro es que la tierra de los kiwis
es un gran país pero ahora turno para ti
crees que nueva zelanda puede ser un
buen modelo a seguir
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta si te ha
gustado el vídeo dale a like y no te
olvides de suscribirte a visual política
si aún no lo has hecho un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]